in this 1995 episode of The Simpsons
Homer walks with march through downtown
Springfield and says whoa careful now
you go dangerous streets for us upper
lower middle class types
this is homers first real admission to
being middle class for the rest of us
this always seemed pretty obvious he
lives in a modest home in the suburbs
with his wife and three children
he's not a college graduate and his job
appears to require a minimal amount of
technical training this is all confirmed
when we get a very tight shot of his
paycheck in season seven hey how come I
don't know according to the stub homers
pre-tax weekly pay of four hundred and
seventy nine dollars and sixty cents
works out to 1199 an hour so he's
looking at an annual salary of twenty
four thousand three hundred and ninety
five dollars adjusted for inflation
that's 37 thousand four hundred and
sixteen dollars per year what this is an
outrage there are a lot of fans who
think the show is based on the real town
of Springfield Oregon
and if we look at homers salary there it
places him pretty comfortably in the
lower middle class income bracket of
course this is all based on one job as a
safety inspector at the Springfield
nuclear power plant but Homer has said
over 191 jobs in 27 seasons and they
placed him across the entire economic
spectrum you know I've had a lot of jobs
sponsor mascot astronaut imitation
Krusty baby-proofer trucker hippy plow
driver food critic conceptual artist
grease salesman carny mayor grifter
bodyguard for the mayor country-western
manager garbage commissioner mountain
climber farmer inventor Smithers Poochie
celebrity assistant power plant worker
fortune cookie writer beer Baron
kwik-e-mart Clerk homophobe and
missionary but protecting Springfield
that gives me the best feeling of all
some of these jobs were literally
impossible to determine salaries for
like beer smuggler or the grim reaper
there were also some seasonal jobs mall
Santa those had to be excluded too in
the end I narrowed Homer's resume down
to a hundred jobs and then I looked at
the average salary for each one here's
what we found
three of Homer's ten highest paying jobs
have been at the power plant in season
thirteen he tried his hand as the
executive vp before momentarily taking
over mr. burns post as CEO the following
season lead ahead of a major corporation
right three years later he served as the
facilities manager
around half of Homer's jobs place him in
the middle class and his least lucrative
jobs were pretty odd he was a mascot a
carny moonshine taste tester a
cannonball performance artist and a
walking billboard was doing there
earning a 200 bucks a week dead what I
plotted out homers hypothetical job
salaries in a linear order by episode
number and over the course of 597
episodes so from 1989 to 2016 it's clear
that he hasn't really ascended
economically despite a few successes
here and there
he has stagnated and that makes him just
like the actual American middle class
until the 1970s the income of the
average American family grew just
alongside the national economic
productivity since then wages have
stagnated and have failed to keep up
with inflation economists have referred
to this as the middle class squeeze we
see homers median income has actually
never surpassed the median income in the
United States despite briefer raisin to
the one-percent Homer remains a paradigm
of middle class America three decades
later he's right where he started
[Music]